[Music]
pause on menopause news submitted by
stop growing Isaac the new medical
procedure could delay the onset of
menopause by 20 years yes my mom went
[ __ ] insane on menopause bro
yes my mom's always been kind of crazy
but this [ __ ] has been nuts what's the
difference from premenopause 3 menopause
is part of it too it's actually the
eternal my mom was went through
menopause
so post menopause this mustache
premenopause is no mustache did my mom
have a man must actually met matter
she's always been menopausal so [ __ ]
is already crazy right yes but on
menopause that [ __ ] is like maybe the
periods is getting them ready for the
menopause so that's like the pre-final
requisite yeah and the final battle is
the menopause and then y'all relax like
old man and then the man start like you
know isn't it after but like once you
went through your menopause and that
means you're not producing estrogen
anymore and you have more testosterone
and then you end up being more
aggressive yeah older so no matter what
we're [ __ ]
menopause is the final boss and then you
beat the game and then like yeah and
then you just turn into a man slowly it
comes like a video game there's just
like I guess the next level yeah yeah so
there's this medical procedure that
they're saying that it will delay
menopause for up to 20 years that's a
lot yeah so what happens during
menopause and stuff is that women end up
having like heart conditions and bone
weakening osteoporosis Wow yeah yeah you
go through some [ __ ] and there's a
there's like in the process of it's like
hot flashes and you lose your libido
who's hot flesh uh you get horny one
last time know how flushes you feel
really hot you thinking of a heat flat D
flat heat flash is like a sudden
horniness no that was a heat wave that a
dead that's a dense that street term
okay cuz I grew up on Chinese movies and
then there's always like the old like
kung fu grandma that's like out of
nowhere it's like oh she'd get so hot I
just a dream like rice wine and then she
goes into like the room she has sex like
one last time
funny I think that's a heatwave yeah to
keep my name Jose right when do women
have menopause around
14050 40s or 50s why I was like oh my
god cuz Nicki's already like you know no
not 40 enough 40 it's later than that
and if he's already Nikki so I'm like oh
man I got like 25 years now and so she
goes even crazier and again nuts dude
okay I don't eat to this or some [ __ ] so
what they're saying is that they can
remove a small piece of ovarian tissue
and then they'll slice it up and freeze
it to preserve it and then once you
start like aging like later on down the
line then they'll put that piece back in
like like through your armpit or
somewhere that is the most ideal
location and once they do that that's
when your body will start producing
those hormones that it lost through that
tissue which then will delay menopause
then they're saying that if you get this
ovarian tissue when you're as young as
like 25 then that's when you can delay
it for like what is it 20 years so then
like the older you are the less you can
delay it that you can do like a stem so
if you're 80 and you do it then it's
like what about Dennis just the same
thing exactly I see yeah I think if
you're 8 it's too late you already went
through it if you're 80 maybe feels like
you're like 78 well I guess you don't
eat like I guess wouldn't wanna not have
better posture pretty much that's I know
and if it's 20 years and you get in your
50s that's pretty much till death yeah
if you delay it maybe you just don't
even yeah it's like right when you're
about to die you go through it you're
like [ __ ] it but to die anyway see
that's why the reason why this cure is
coming on is because there's no [ __ ]
menopause industry no dude
like like hair [ __ ] come on dude you
think there's no actual pill out there
that you could take to restore all your
hair I believe that there probably is
but all these hair care products billion
dollars industries like conspiracy yeah
[ __ ] you
but menopause there's never been like a
cash cow for menopause like oh yeah
we're making shitload of money on
menopause until now well no that's why
they're coming out the cure would you
guys want to go through menopause like
eighty rather than fifty [ __ ] yeah
really late I don't want to go through
all that jet does this thing keep the
ladies looking young too then
I do hear like your metabolism slows
down and a lot of women have like been
like damn I gained so much weight it's
just even harder to lose it but with the
menopause yeah but I don't know if
that's just the lack of like knowledge
or it's true they just don't want to
look like bullfrogs because when women
can't hold they kind of look like
bullfrogs I've noticed really everyone's
trying to stay young all day you know
that reading this article he said that
just a hundred years ago they the life
expectancy it was 50 up to 50 so then
women would go through menopause just
for a short amount of time that were
living longer now women are going
through menopause for decades that's
true a long time think about all those
grandmas in Okinawa that are like a
hundred and twenty years old
damn and yes I go through all that [ __ ]
I wonder what else what else is there to
live for no wonder they just [ __ ]
gross [ __ ] in their garden all day and
do nothing is permit LLL sign of
menopause that's a pretty good side but
usually your hair straight and then you
go through menopause it's like now you
when you go to the salon site I need
that perm I don't think it's the perm I
think it's a couple things I think it's
the hair being gray and the constant
dying and then the other one is you lose
a lot of your hair so it's really thin
so then you want some sort of volume oh
that's what well then you start thinking
gaudy sweaters like pretty cool yeah oh
I should get that sweater with the
flower pattern all over it and then the
strong smells too I just thought that
style was always like they just got
stuck in it ya know like like they just
got you hearty good yeah I think you
reached the age of these dirt-kicking
that looks cool oh really yeah well then
you start thinking of comfort and then
your eyes that you might be like oh that
colors too bright yeah my grandma when
she was in her 20s she's still just like
the way that she did like until her
death she had a perm though her hair was
kind of curly and permed yeah did she
wear a lot of curtain patterns and like
yeah I mean I think she has some of the
same dresses from her youth that she cuz
baby bed clothes that just lasted and
[ __ ] does her grandma wear tons of
pearls and white gloves she does well
not the white gloves but she does wear
like pearls in like some really like 60s
jewelry that she kept from this day like
her purses and her shoe
I'm like you look so cute my mom is the
same way too I saw it like a old picture
of her and their youth same dress and
I'm like I know that [ __ ] thing you
wore the same thing like god damn that's
a 40 year old dress and I think there
are smell starts to go so they put on
perfume in like oh I don't think I put
it on and they're like oh that's right
yeah how do they gotta choose the most
nastiest smells to like go to bath and
body working yes smell really good and
then I would choose watermelon or
something like it once I reach that age
and I think like if I can't smell it
I'll just have like someone like my
granddaughter or something but I came to
something nice for you your mom seems
nice it doesn't sound like this smell
plunging dude when you get in their car
on a hot day and then you just smell the
perfume the whole time you're like
trying a wall window down like holy [ __ ]
that's when it gets nuts it's like fake
Rose smell OH
I feel like as we're like certain ages
you have different types of smell but
you're like into what it is just like
food I know you're little you didn't
like like that [ __ ] grandparents
flavor [ __ ] and you're like oh it's
healthy and I think like I'm sorry to
like cream juice
I was like yeah but see when you get old
you start to say thought before saying
things like prune juice oh you like wall
I was on the fringes I don't know I
don't know man I heard it from a lot of
people it always freaks me out and then
like my grandma she falls asleep
anywhere we are oh my god that's a power
like a superpower my grandma had a hard
time falling asleep Joyce had to smoke
cigarettes before oh my god she sleeps
throughout the day around a moment and
she snores really loudly
yeah um cuz she got like secondhand
smoke so she has like breathing problems
and [ __ ] and so when we're at night
though like she'll sleep over she's uh
night no she's up the whole night
insomnia she's like doing things like
washing dishes and stuffing on my
grandma go to sleep like her sleeping
schedule she's like a baby you really
end up going back to being a baby the
older you get hard you sleep less when
you become all old and [ __ ] you sleep a
lot more when you're yes because you
have to take naps during the day and my
grandparents slept like five or six
hours like you before I am all the time
because you but they also take nabs
there your whole family has a heavy nap
culture what are you talking to my
grandpa didn't map he did maybe four
hours of sleep at night maybe four and a
half hours yeah but they're sleeping
throughout the day man
no this fool did not never drink
throughout the day he with his eyes open
he would not sleep you did not that he's
not in that we thought that was [ __ ]
when he got bored he'd go to Costco and
spend like $700 and he's just getting
food for two people you like grandpa
there's no such thing right you're
always getting food for ten right
exactly so he would do that and he's
like does anyone want a rotisserie
[ __ ] chicken or something yeah I
bought seven over cuz I don't know I was
the deal he and my father taught me that
they're like look at the ounces never
look at the [ __ ] sticker look at the
ounces ounces my dollar per ounces on
the thing that's that's where they [ __ ]
you the hardest yeah you think it's
cheaper because it's five bucks and then
the other ones ten dollars and you look
at how much yeah this is paying thirty
three cents an ounce
yeah like or is here you're paying
eighteen cents an ounce that's the
[ __ ] deal you don't need more fifty
have storage in your house no can you
make surgeon - no - can you put the
funnier Bell you have a trunk no space
under the bed no don't you have like a
book she'll have nothing
oh I think I need more toothpaste like
you could never have enough because you
gotta go out and buy it anyway didn't
have a son you would have a whole room
that you could put all these deals into
just saying extreme coupon I say return
em and go get the deal it's a way better
deal
I got a good deal on toothpaste
travel-size I still have it for it to
this day baby toothpaste I got you and
you got a lot of toothpaste
yeah cuz you want the deal no I've
actually received a lot of toothpaste
for summer where do you put all the
toothpaste that
I put them in the trash in the trash
exactly
yeah I get rid of good deal well how are
you gonna give us all your extra
toothpaste if you did that go dig in the
trash do you I don't know got you - you
have a secret storage spot that we don't
know about for them to find it it's in
my automatic I'm coming over to your
place for a barbecue and I'm gonna be
snooping if you don't need okay you just
said you have some Moree that you don't
you know I'm using it still I'm saying
it's lasting this long because I have a
huge box of it maybe you don't need
anyone else need to think I'll take
something something yeah you could never
have enough toothpaste I just realized
that toothpaste is like that like this
big there's like but we use toothpaste
all the time so why doesn't it come in
like tub form like really big let you
just stick your tooth brushing yeah does
it go bad I think like two years like a
paint bucket so we just scoop our brush
in yeah a lot of to things but that's
the deal you always need to yeah because
we never we never not need them that's
what I'm saying because every time and
no one's gonna look at you like you're
so greedy hoarding all that toothpaste
no no it's like everyone understands cuz
you're like yeah you kind of need it
till you die yeah that's a genius idea
thank you for that
[Music]